字幕: Chika Mizuta
校正: Hiroko Kawano
ここに 美味しそうなサンドイッチがあります
でも このサンドイッチの販売期限は
あと５秒で切れます
たった今 このサンドイッチは
ゴミ箱に行くしかなくなりました
（ゴミ箱の音）
このように まだ美味しく食べられるのに
捨てられてしまう食べ物が
「フードロス」と呼ばれています
残念ながら このフードロスが
日本の至る所で発生しているのが現状です
こうしたフードロスに一番
影響を与えるのは誰だと思いますか？
それは 私たち消費者です
私も一人の消費者として
このフードロスという課題に
３年前から関わってきました
私がフードロスに関わるようになったのは
小学校２年生の時に
白血病を患ったことがきっかけでした
１年半という長い闘病生活の中で
一番つらかったのは食事でした
自分が食べたいものが食べられず
子供にとって味付けが薄すぎる病院食を
毎日食べるのがとても苦痛でした
看護師さんに隠れて カップラーメンを食べて
怒られてしまったこともあります
闘病生活の後
私は食事を制限されていた反動から
人一倍食に対して執着するようになり
ついには「食」にしか
興味が湧かなくなってしまいました
その後 私は大学生になり
食関連の仕事を探して
私がずっと憧れだったカフェで働き始めました
そこで バイトリーダーになった私は
発注業務を任せてもらえるようになりました
そこで驚いたのは
そのお店が 必ずフードロスが出るように
発注をするマニュアルになっていたことです
私の憧れだったカフェは
なぜそんな もったいないことを
していたのでしょうか？
それは お店が閉店間際まで
品揃えを用意しておくことが
いわゆる「サービス」の一部と
なっていたからです
お客様が閉店間際まで商品を選べることが
たとえ その商品が捨てられてしまうとしても
発注すべきという考え方だったのです
私はずっと
捨てる前提のサンドイッチを発注して
閉店時には それを
当たり前のように捨てていました
「私は 自分が食べたくても
食べられない時期があったのに
今では自分の手で
サンドイッチを捨ててしまっている
なんでこんなことが
当たり前になっているんだろう？」と
働いている間ずっと疑問でした
このアルバイトの経験がきっかけで
私は フードロスという社会課題に
興味を持ち 調べるようになりました
その結果分かったのは
フードロスはこのお店のせいでもなく
誰のせいでもないということです
そもそもフードロスという社会課題は
なぜ発生するのでしょうか？
それは大量生産 大量消費の時代以降
資本主義社会の中でできた考え方が
原因となっています
「お客様が来店した時に
商品がないという機会損失よりも
余るほど生産して捨てた方が経済的に良い」
という概念から生まれています
[１人当たりの年間食品廃棄量（kg）]
実際 世界では毎年13億トンもの
フードロスが発生しています
日本はその中でも
１人当たりの年間フードロス量が
世界で６番目に多く
年間で 612万トンもの
フードロスを発生させています
一方で 日本の食料自給率は
平成30年度のカロリーベースで37%と低く
食料を輸入に頼っている状況です
つまり私たちは
過剰に生産、輸入された食品を
食べることなく日々廃棄しています
これは生産過程で消費した資源が
無駄になるだけではなく
無駄にCO2を排出して
環境負荷を上げてしまっていることです
こうしたフードロスの現状を聞いていると
「自分の生活には直接影響がない
別に今日明日の食べ物に
困るわけじゃないし
ただ倫理的にダメなことっていうだけでしょ」
という風に捉える方がいますが
それは違います
フードロスという課題が進むと
私たち消費者の今の
「食べたいものが食べられる」という生活が
成り立たなくなる可能性があります
例えば このまま世界人口が
97億人になったときに
限られた食糧が常に
日本に輸入されるでしょうか？
日本は食糧自給率が低く
もし万が一輸入が止められた場合
国内生産の食糧に頼るしかなくなります
そうすると 今の私たちの
「食べたいものが食べられる」という暮らしが
成り立たなくなる可能性があります
私達は今 持続可能ではない食生活を
ずっと続けている状態なのです
話を聞いていると
大変なことのように
感じられるかもしれません
実はフードロスは ひとごとではなかったと
そして この現状を解決していくには
私たち消費者の働きかけが不可欠です
しかし 先ほどのデータや現状を聞いていると
もう手遅れなんじゃないか
消費者一人が何か頑張っても
得られる効果は薄いんじゃないかと
悲観してしまうかもしれません
しかし 私たち消費者が
店側や飲食店に対して
規格外商品でも買いたい
期限が近いものでも買いたいと
意思表示することにより
店側の行動に 変化を起こすことができます
実際に消費者が
お店に働きかけやすくなるように
私が取り組んでいることが ２つあります
１つがフードシェアリングサービス
「TABETE」です
TABETEは 近くの飲食店で
余ってしまったものを
お得に購入できるテイクアウトサービスで
現在30万人の方がアプリに
登録していただいています
また これまでに約４万食が救われました
ユーザーの多くは
「社会貢献ができてうれしい」
という風に話しております
また TABETEのユーザー約600人に
回答していただいたアンケートにて
TABETEの利用前後で
どれほどフードロスへの関心度合いが
高まったかを検証しました
利用前は 「フードロスへの関心がある」
と回答された方は48%でしたが
TABETEを利用後には 94%にまで増加しました
このアンケート結果から
余った食事を TABETEを通して
購入することにより
消費者のフードロス削減への
貢献意識が高まったと言えます
TABETEを導入した店舗さんは
「こんなに需要があるとは思わなかった」
「今まで廃棄していた食品の量を
見直すきっかけになった」
と話していました
これは消費者が買い物を通して
社会貢献をしただけではなく
店舗側の意識を変えるきっかけになった
という一つの例になります
２つ目が「レスキューデリ」という事業です
レスキューデリとは 閉店後に
駅の中で余ってしまった食品を
私たちが安く買い取り
駅従業員の方にお得に販売する取り組みです
これは 実際に 東京駅にある
駅ナカ施設の閉店後に
私たちが買い取った食品の写真です
まだまだ食べられる
美味しそうなパンやお弁当を
毎晩このくらいの量を買い取って
販売していました
実際に2020年の1月に
１ヶ月間実施した時には
１ヶ月間で 約１トンものフードロスを
削減することができました
参加した飲食店さんにお話を聞いたときに
飲食店さんは
「このレスキューデリの取り組みで
捨てる量がかなり多く減り
そのおかげで罪悪感も軽くなった」
と話していました
また 当たり前に今まで廃棄していた物が
最後まで誰かに食べてもらえるという風に
改めて認識を持ったという風に話していました
これも駅ナカの消費者である従業員が
飲食店に働きかけることにより
店舗の認識が変わった事例です
では このような取り組みを踏まえて
私たち消費者はフードロス削減に向けて
何ができるのでしょうか？
１つ目は フードロス商品や規格外商品を
店側に対して積極的に販売を求め
そしてそれを買うことです
TABETEやレスキューデリも その１つですが
それに限らず フードロス商品や
規格外商品を買うことで
店側に対して
フードロス商品に需要があるということを
知ってもらうきっかけになります
２つ目は SNSで発信をすることです
訳アリ商品のことでもいいですし
フードロス商品を買ったら
それを購入した時に SNSで発信すること
例えば 面白い形の野菜を買ったなら
それを共有してみんなで楽しむこと
そして フードレスキューを
ただの義務や問題解決法として
捉えるだけではなく
ポジティブなこととして
トレンドにしていくことが必要です
またこれは 他の人がそういった商品を
知るきっかけになるだけではなく
そういった商品を買うことが
当たり前であるという考え方を
広めることもできます
３つ目は フードロス削減に取り組むお店を
批判するのでも 傍観するのでもなく
あらゆる形で応援することです
２年前までは
賞味期限が近い商品を
販売する店舗に対しては
「売れ残った商品を販売している」だとか
「腐りかけの商品を販売している」
というように
否定的な声が上げられてきました
しかしここ数年 メディアや
行政の力によって認知拡大が進み
かなり そのイメージが改善されてきました
私たちが本来するべきことは
勇気を持ってフードロス削減に
取り組み始めた店舗を
否定するのではなく
褒め称えることです
私たち消費者の応援なくして
フードロス削減の取り組みは広がりません
ここまで フードロスの現状や
私たち消費者がフードロス削減に
向けてできることについて
お話ししてきました
フードロスは他人ごとではなく
私たち消費者一人一人の生活に
直接影響する社会課題です
だからこそ 私たち消費者が
積極的に取り組んでいく必要があります
こうした取り組みを通して
私たちがフードロス削減に
取り組むことができれば
誰も食べない食料を
過剰に生産することを抑え
地球資源の無駄使いを減らすことができると
私は 信じています